let's talk about this first story we got
from timcast.com
new mexico man acquitted of charges
related to january 6. the federal
defense contractor is the first person
to be found not guilty of all charges
filed against him in connection to the
capital security breach matthew martin a
federal defense contractor was acquitted
on april 6 following a two-day bench
trial martin had been charged with
entering and remaining in a restricted
building disorderly and disruptive
conduct in a restricted building
violent entry and disorderly conduct in
a capitol building and parading
demonstrating or picketing in a capitol
building u.s district judge trevor n
mcvadden said that the first charge of
entering and remaining in a restricted
building was a close call but that there
was a reasonable doubt whether martin
knew he was entering a restricted
building mcfadden also said the
government failed to show evidence of
martin crossing the police line which
mobs of protesters had broken before he
had arrived at the capitol during his
april 5th testimony martin said he went
with the flow
so here we are this is fascinating
for the people who tore down the
barricades tore the the signs down
attacked cops well of course they're
going to get convicted there's video
evidence of them attacking people but
we've long maintained that there is
reasonable doubt for those the magami
maws they call them who fumbled and
bumbled their way into the building as
police fanned them in so uh can i say i
was right that was right yeah no you're
absolutely correct i was right
because i said this back in january
andrew clavin's seal of approval you
know very it's very rare that federal
cases go to trial because people are so
terrified by the federal government
because the federal government doesn't
mess around when they put you away for
15 years you stay away for 15 years
there's no time off for good behavior so
when they come to you and they say well
we'll give you four years instead people
confess and they plead guilty
but but you don't you just don't have to
do it especially if there was as in this
case there was video of the guy being
let in that's right yeah and this is the
video that we referenced back in january
where you see the door open and then
there's there's actual audio where you
can hear a cop say i don't agree with it
but i would but i respect it or
something like that that's a cop yeah
you've got cops taken selfies with
protesters so this is the third jury
this is the third trial there's been one
jury trial and two bench trials the
bench trial with uh judge um mcfadden i
believe his name is mcfadden
the guy was acquitted on the the charges
of disorderly or whatever
it was like just entering isn't
disorderly so acquitted but you did you
know climb up an outer wall and you knew
you weren't supposed to be in there so
you're getting trespassed right but
what's that really going to be i think
the the entire january 6th narrative is
in the gutter at this point what you
have you have that that uh disc
disconnect between the democrats
narrative and what happened what
happened was bad i don't think you
should charge into the capital i don't
think you should make our congress
people afraid except of being dis you
know unelected
but they've turned it into the reichstag
fire they've turned it into the biggest
emergency that ever hit the country and
now we need all you know now every
republican is supposed to feel like a
criminal and that's ridiculous let's
look uh let's let me pull up the scene
in a headline real quick this is how cnn
frames it man who said january 6 was
magical acquitted in u.s capital riot
case you see
this is why people don't understand
what's happening in the world
because when you see that headline and
you're a cnn reader or viewer you assume
this guy
is a writer who is violent they called
it a riot case he said it was magical
but they don't give you the context in
the headline right of course
yeah i mean it's ridiculous you
mentioned earlier the fact that the
federal government tends to convict i
think their prosecution rate is
something above 95 because like you said
people are usually willing to take plea
deals
and it's not as if they're sitting there
messing around looking for reasons to
let somebody off they weren't able to
convict this guy because there was
reasonable doubt whether he
intentionally trespassed and there have
been at this point dozens if not
hundreds of people who were there who
have repeated this narrative that they
were waved in by the police they did not
know they weren't supposed to be there
obviously people who broke in who
legitimately trespassed who broke down
the barriers like you mentioned
those are criminals but there are many
people who thought that they were
allowed to be there based on the conduct
of the police and so for the young turks
to come smear you because you speak my
goodness
the good name besmirched the good name
of sir timothy cast over his prediction
which turned out to be correct is
frankly hilarious they own themselves
you know what gets me really is that the
process is the punishment in this
situation this i did this guy sit in
solitary for a year like a lot of these
other people probably so he's like in a
state of mind was like i'm going to take
it to court because i got nothing left
to lose at this point if they're going
to leave me in jail for a year without
you know due process
i'm not trying to rain on this because
this is great news this is really good
news and it's it's definitely an
indication that a lot more acquittals
are coming well here's what i'm curious
about so if we see more acquittals i
wonder which direction that is going to
build political momentum because on the
one hand it could result in people
saying that the entire narrative was
nonsensical and revolting against
democrats as a result or maybe it could
embolden democrats to say these people
are getting away with an insurrection
even though that's complete nonsense and
the judge was appointed by donald trump
yeah there is that but i i still think i
think that people have got this exactly
right they know it was bad they
shouldn't shouldn't have done it but
they also know that democrats have just
played and played and played this card
until it's it's absolutely maxed out you
know well
i'm sick of it yeah i think i think when
november comes along we have a very good
likelihood a very strong likelihood that
republicans are going to get in the
question is are republicans going to do
anything and i'm not entirely convinced
the january 6 committee will be gone
yeah and then the republican party will
twiddle its thumbs and fall asleep the
republicans get kicked out of office for
not doing what they say they'll do and
democrats get kicked out for doing what
they say they'll do i mean because
because republicans if they would
actually follow as trump did in fact if
they would actually deliver on their
conservative promises everything gets
better you know what are some of the
promises that you like that you thought
should have got followed through on
by whom just conservatives in general
that you've noticed well i think for
instance immigration reform you know
maybe we could stop people from pouring
in over the over the border forever you
know i think every country on earth has
a border why don't we that's that's
always a good one i think cutting back
on some of the entitlement that have
driven us so far into debt that we're
essentially a debtor nation with very
little chance of getting climbing our
way out i think that um you know the
kinds of things that are happening in
disneyland uh the magical kingdom which
has become even more magical if you
happen to be slightly odd uh you know i
think those are the kinds of things that
a president should address one of one of
the things i thought was great about
trump was that he fought the culture
wars and i think that that's why he got
elected and that's why he was where he
was can confirm i was uh i went to a
bunch of the trump rallies and the young
men that i met said political
correctness was a huge reason why they
were voting for trump they felt that
trump's potty mouth was a pullback or
you know that would pull everything back
to normalcy in terms of our ability to
speak no question i mean it's just no
question for for 50 years 60 years
they've been telling people in this
country their country stinks their
religion is untrue they're racist
they're sexist they you know everything
about them is terrible and their history
is terrible all the pride that america
had for a country that after all did
defeat both soviet communism and nazism
uh and and was the only republic in the
world when it started was the you know
it actually turned being a republic into
the default position
all of that pride that we had was just
absolutely stomped on for 50 60 years
and then they wondered why did they
elect donald trump well they elected
donald trump because he told these
people where to go so you think it was
the military industrial complex the the
liberal economic order the formation
1946 that just just annihilated that's
what i think it is anyway what do you
mean well in 1946 after world war ii
they decided we don't want world war ii
we're going to set up this liberal
economic order and put american military
apparently our british military bases a
lot of them then the americans took them
set up all these military bases we're
like we're the world police but it seems
like they're using the federal reserve
to over print military military more
bombs more blow up waste money and they
destroyed our economy and our will it's
not it's not it's not the military that
destroys our economy it is the uh
entitlements that cannot be stopped
you know you can't you can't vote the
entitlements out without destroying them
and once the government gives you
something nobody ever gives it back so
though i view this as uh putting a
band-aid on abandoned and a band-aid so
we get a wound in this country of some
sort like a housing crisis and then
we're like quick what do we do to heal
this wound we put a band-aid on it mass
spending or welfare welfare programs and
it may be a simple solution to everybody
like okay we'll just you know we've got
it we've got a food we've got an
economic crisis let's give a stimulus to
everybody to keep them afloat for now
slapping a bandit on the wound then a
few weeks later when the wound starts
festering they say you better slap
another bandage over that so instead of
cleaning it off
taking the bandage off cleaning the
wound putting a new bandaid on we've
just stacked piles and piles of bandages
on bandages
i'm a little bit i see it in a little
bit more of a sinister light um nobody
ever gives anybody anything right
there's no such thing as a free lunch
the word free is actually not english
that doesn't actually refer to anything
that exists except maybe the moon and
the stars you know the best things in
life are free but but nothing is free so
when somebody gives you something you
have to ask what's the price when
somebody gives you you know a free lunch
you ask what are they asking for every
time they give you something it costs
you your freedom oh sure sure sure but
come on that's not true in every case i
mean facebook's free
there we go i think in like the same
with trump's potty mouth i think if the
technocratic spy state wasn't in effect
the potty mouth may have actually
you know brought people back to a state
of sandy or at least a state where they
could they could ruby i have mixed
feelings on the potty mouth what were we
going to say sheamus
you know you you mentioned that uh when
something's free someone's actually
covertly taking something from you
timcast.com is not free so i'm letting
you guys know to plug for things
yeah money we'll just take your money
look now you know patreon.com freedom
tooth is it free either i'm like i know
i do like how
the idea of facebook being free was just
so absurd everyone laughed at the idea
at the idea because facebook is so awful
oh that's not why you said did you see
that mark zuckerberg said his employees
endearingly call him the eye of sauron
he thinks that's endearing this kind of
worries me a little bit actually
it's amazing that
i that is he really there's no way he
believes that lack of self-awareness i
think he's spying on everybody that he
work that works for him but he thinks
it's
fine yeah because he's a nice guy he
would never misuse it oh it's terrifying
all right did you ever see terminator 2
you know miles dyson the guy was like
well if i'd known i was going to build
the terminator i'll stop right now
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you